My time has finally come.
Today, I get to talk about Cephalopods
Hey guys, Julia here for Dnews
Octopi and their fellow cephalopods scare
the living daylights out of my sister.
Something about a traumatic trip on the 20,000
leagues under the Sea Ride….
So sister, you should probably turn off this
episode, because it turns out, there’s a
lot to be afraid of.
Okay in my opinion there’s a lot to love
about these molluscs.
Like a recent discovery that some species
of octopuses can see through their skin.
Seriously.
Octopuses make a chemical in their eyes called
opsins, which react to light, and send a chemical
signal to the brain.
In two studies published in the journal of
Experimental Biology, researchers found that
these molecules can also be found in their
skin.
In octopuses, these molecules are in nerve
endings on the cell.
These little hair like extensions detected
light and send a chemical signal to specialized
color changing cells on their skin called
chromatophores.
In other cephalopods like squid and cuttlefish,
opsins are actually found in the chromatophores
themselves.
Scientists think this might be how cephalopods
have such an uncanny ability to blend into
their surroundings.
Oh yeah these guys are masters of camouflage.
I mean, some cephalopods have have up to 96,000
chromatophores per square inch of skin.
Each of these chromatophores contain a sac
of pigment surrounded by muscle and by stretching
or squeezing this sac, they can change the
appearance of their colors.
Some species of cephalopods have other crazy
color cells, like iridophores which make iridescent
colors, or leucophores which mirror back the
environment.
But besides changing colors, some cephalopods
can change texture.
yeah crazy, In a study published in the Journal
of Morphology researchers found that cephalopods
have small muscular structures on their skin
that either poke up vertically in a spike
or bump or spread out nice and smooth.
So they can morph into crazy patterns and
changing textures in their environment, like
mimicking corals, rocks or sand.
Or mimicking other sea creatures like T. mimicus,
an Indo-Pacific species of octopus.
Not only are they great pretenders but they
are crazy crazy smart.
Like they’ve been known to pull pranks and
play in captivity.
According to Canadian biologist Jennifer Mather,
they blow water at stuff in their tanks or
take apart stuff like robots, just for the
fun of it.
And play is something thought to only be found
in intelligent creatures, like birds and apes.
There’s so many stories of them sneaking
out of their tanks at night and stealing a
fish or two from a nearby tank then plopping
back in their tank and acting like nothing
happened.
Mather even noticed that octopuses have personalities,
different creatures are more shy or active
than others.
These come from their big brains, well relatively.
They’re brains aren’t as big as ours per
say, but bigger than many other molluscs.
Most molluscs have “brains” that are actually
clusters of nerve cells spread throughout
the body.
But cephalopods have a more centralized group
of these ganglia, or nerve cells.
This centralizes command in the creature and
provides more room for developing things like
memory.
They also have little mini brains or groups
of nerve cells in their arms!
I haven’t even mentioned that cuttlefish
are adorable and cuddly… an octopus has
a beak or some species have an arm, called
a A hectocotylus, that acts a lot like penis
by storing and transferring sperm to the female.
Which just gets weird.
Speaking of the weird and wonderful, Laci
explains all about real life sea monsters
in this great video here …